et puis j'observe qu'il ya beaucoup
effectivement de potentiel tête de liste
pour ce grand mouvement central tout ce
qui est une femme je ne sais pas que je
propose que le fameux x se prononce et
puis je voulais quand même dire une
chose c'est que on n'a en tête que ces
élections c'est en juin 2019 et on sait
que d'ici là je pense qu'un certain
nombre de choses qui se sont déjà qui
s'esquisse déjà sur l'extrême droite sur
la question du break 6 devons rester
extrêmement active donc on peut penser
qu'effectivement le logiciel d'emmanuel
matches on sera toujours utile au moment
de ces élections mais qui seront quand
même des élections de mi mandat
donc je sais pas si à leur place je
ferais à ce point le le pari des manuels
macron je pense que ça montre aussi un
vide de leurs de leur côté et peut-être
un peu de précipitation
et puis moi je fais le pari aussi que
peut-être la différence entre la droite
et la gauche aura retrouvé un petit peu
de poil de la bête
j'entendais que vous disiez que le ps
était mort je suis pas sûr que le fait
que le parti socialiste soit mort veut
dire que la gauche soit morte ni que la
droite soit morte
même si les républicains vont mal et
donc la question qui se pose avant de se
rassembler là vous disiez au fond il ya
de la cohérence intellectuelle du côté
d'alain juppé il ya une coréen cohérence
en tout cas d'amitié par rapport à
edouard philippe
et donc à partir de là le projet il faut
il faut quand même y travailler moi
c'est ça que je souhaite dire j'aimerais
qu'on en discute sur le plateau est ce
que ça sera le même projet du côté de la
gauche et de la droite pour ces
élections européennes face à l'extrême
droite face aux grecs site face à
l'élargissement de l'union européenne
csah les questions qui sont posées